How does HTTP work?
In its original
form, Berners-Lee
came up with a template
that you can fill in
to make a request for
a document on a server.
The original protocol,
later called HTTP 0.9,
was incredibly limited.
You fill in if you want
to retrieve or store
a document, where to
store the document,
including the name and
any additional information
you think is necessary.
This request is then
handed to the server.
Since the server
speaks HTTP, it
knows that this is an HTTP
request and can, therefore,
understand what
the client wants.
The protocol also has
templates for the responses.
These are a bit more versatile,
since a single request
can have a variety of outcomes,
including errors, unreadable
request forms, or redirecting
the client to a completely
different server.
Luckily, Rich did a good job,
and I know what he wants.
The only thing left for me
to do is fill out this form
so Richard knows which
request I'm responding to.
Bandwidth problems.